b b big day big huge big Taran Manning
is here you know her from such giant
movies as eight mile Hustle and Flow
Crossroads Crossroads with Britney
Spears Shalom uh she was incredible on
oranges the New Black her performance is
Bonkers in that show she has a very
special place in my heart because her
band boomcat has a song on the Eight
Mile soundtrack it's called you're just
wasting my time
big this song's a big deal for me all
right for years I mean almost going on
15 years now whenever I was like dating
some dude who was just a trash garbage
nothing man that wore tank tops and
scarves like not worth it but for some
reason my childhood compelled me to
chase them even though they had a chain
wallet and a tattoo of an Edgar Allen
poke quote on their old rib cage I would
put on this song and it would set me
straight okay that's what it that this
song I'm telling you makes you move on
it's like my move on from him anthem for
literally 15 years now you should use it
is actually a great tool to help you
move on from that
tool anyway of course I'm making this
about me by accident um Taran recently
had a very big public shaming and you
know me by now you know me you know that
I love having triggering people on the
podcast in borderline Japanese
appropriation shirts um I think that I
like to have like people in this moment
I think I identify as a triggering
person like I see myself I'm loud and
I'm opinionated and I say wild shit
which I sometimes believe sometimes
don't it can be factious or I'm just
trying to keep a conversation
interesting I don't know I change my
mind every day I'm happier that way but
I don't know I feel like Comics we get a
pass to be like that you know because we
get away with it more because you know
that we're all hanging by a thread and
that we live and die for your approval
maybe that's why but Taran got a ton of
blowback for a couple things we're going
to dig into all of them with
her I've been following it like a hawk
okay it's to me just been a fascinating
example of how I tend to think of public
figures as a warshock test like everyone
everyone who was mad about the cheating
scand ofal guy remember him my most
outraged girlfriends were always the
ones who had been cheated on or
suspected they were being cheated on and
the guys who felt the need to criticize
him were always the people I know to be
chronic cheaters like it kind of says
more about you than it says about them I
feel like like remember when Tiger Woods
cheated um hip reference um remember
when he cheated and guys were all
defending him and they'd be like I mean
he's like the best golfer in the world
and you're like yeah that's your like it
your reaction to this says so much more
about you because it's like he's the
best golfer in the world and which by
the way
that means that he has the most focused
the most self-control the most ability
to think clearly and he has the means to
go to coup's therapy or get a divorce
lawyer so why again does that mean he's
allowed to have 18 different secret
Mistresses because professional golfers
always need 18 holes what's the logic I
don't follow so it's been interesting
talking to people about the Taran
Manning thing um and because it sort of
tells me more about them you know it's
interesting to see people's reactions to
what you know Taran had this really
rough video and then now she's sort of
posting pretty interesting video look if
you haven't seen the first one she
posted a video on Tik Tok when I saw I
was definitely worried uh for sure she
admitted to hanging out with a married
man and wanting to buy him a boat she
talked about licking his tush hole which
I don't last night on her Instagram live
she called a butthole a balloon knot
which is objectively
hilarious it's like she's hilarious dude
and and I just see what she's going
through and I don't know what she's
going through we're going to find out
today we haven't sat down yet but I've
been very straight up with y'all about
my little mental journey I went on in
January after my mom passed away I had a
touch of the Mania I was smoking too
much weed I started investigating the
Scientology ships started digging into a
couple unsolved murders started feeding
and trying to train my
crows I still call the my crows which
means we haven't made a ton of mental
progress but look I'm sure a lot of
people thought I was losing it and crazy
but I was in grief you know I had gone
off birth control went off Prozac I was
actually going off drugs which was way
worse I guess for me um I had a doop of
the paranoia from that California ganja
and it was the perfect storm that led me
uh to a situation where Tim Dylan came
to my home and he was like we're worried
about you and I was like who me don't be
worried about me you be worried about
how China just bought the house down the
street and is using it as a secret
lab I mean that is literally was my
reaction I mean they are China is buying
up a lot of La real estate I just and I
do think Scientology uses the land but
if I say that I sound crazy for some
reason anyway I guess when I see someone
being publicly shamed after they made a
boo boo I I usually want to protect that
person for whatever reason maybe it's
growing up in alcoholic home and
protecting my mom from being in Ed or
maybe I'm just an American hero I don't
know but taran's situation is also kind
of making me think about like who gets
away with what and why like you know
people are mad that you know Taran
Manning hung out with a married man okay
fine not ideal whatever but Angelina
Jolie gets to have a
career she gets to have a career even
though wasn't Brad Pit with Jen Aniston
I mean sorry to rehash a bunch of old
stuff I'm like Tiger Woods and Brad
jelina I'm just
look I just feel like we brushed that
under the carpet Angelina got a pass
because I don't know she has high
cheekbones and a bunch of genderless
kids with mohawks like why does she get
I don't know also maybe it's this Taran
Manning has said that she likes Donald
Trump fine okay a lot of Hollywood
people are pro Trump and they just don't
admit it that's that's what I like about
her she just she says what most people
should keep secret and maybe she should
keep this stuff secret but I I admire it
you know um I also find it very weird
that you'd be mad at someone because
they have a different political
affiliation than you it's parties I just
feel like first of all you're a dork if
you believe in political parties at all
parties are just teams at this point we
all know politics is Just Sports for
dork so she's rooting for the other team
fine that's like not being friends with
an Eagles fan because you're a Redskins
fan and yes I still say Redskins I'm not
saying commanders it's just I grew up in
DC and it's just too nerdy for me sorry
another thing that seems to be pissing
people off about Taran is that she loves
the
L she reads the Bible she talks about
God which can be very upsetting to you
Savages out there you Godless cretans I
I just feel like in Hollywood there's a
big prejudice against people that are
Christian for sure but the people who do
criticize the people who believe in God
are the same people who charge their
crystals and believe in
polyamory their religion is trying to
convince 22-year- old actresses that
monogamy is not natural but getting
clamydia from a talent agent is so you
decide by the way this was my point
about sound of freedom it came off as a
Christian movie everyone thought it was
a Christian movie I think it's because
Jim cavel is who played Jesus he was the
main guy in the Jesus movie or he played
Jesus so everyone thought it was
Christian whatever I say God all right
I'm in a 12-step program I pray but
that's just because if I don't I'll
worship the altar of Edibles and that'll
hit my head on the Altar and die the
same way Avana Trump did kidding she was
pushed out a flight of stairs as soon as
galain was going to publish the flight
manifest anyway the point is I have seen
all of taran's videos I was worried I'm
gonna of course I was wor I was worried
I thought the same things that you guys
did but then in a lot of the videos
she's making a lot of sense she's
dropping a lot of real AF facts but what
she was saying was absolutely getting
lost in how she was saying it like she
revealed that a big movie she did never
paid her but in the video she was
wearing biking shorts in a Parker which
is a Vibe you know she does sometimes
look like Axel Rose is doing the Walk of
Shame out of Drake's house I think it's
cool but I get why you guys it throws
you I'm just saying if she said a lot of
the stuff that she was saying in a desk
in a suit with great hair and great
lighting or if she was on daak Shepard's
podcast she'd be lauded as like a
silence breaker she'd be a brave
outspoken disruptor you know I mean
she's been calling out some wild abuse
in Hollywood and I guess I just have a
soft spot for her I as someone who had
Bonkers hair as someone who looked like
Chucky for like six months during the
pandemic I know what it's like to have
people think you've lost your mind and
are on drugs because you don't know how
to use leave and conditioner and won't
stop yelling about the Saudis putting
money into
Disney so I'm gonna stop talking uh we
haven't done the interview yet so
hopefully this monologue still makes
sense after the interview is done
without further Ado the internet's
current self-righteous indignation
fodder please welcome Taran
Manning
turn let ask you is this okay to have on
the screen we deliberated is that cuz
we're going to I mean we don't have to
get into this but I didn't want to is
that not Britney Spears Britney we had
to shut down in the set because she got
acne pizza
face well it happened listen I had adult
acne as well guys it wasn't a great
day and they were the proper ones it was
like a full-blown and it was like the
white heads like you could you could
cover it so set we're like like oh you
have two weeks off okay what's happening
well something Terrible's
happened Britney's had a break out of
some some some acne it was called I was
like oh boy and then she went to Sonia
drar yep Sonia drar uh healed her and we
came back to work and it was a great
yeah we're like we're back and it was
gone acne doesn't go away that quick I'm
like what' you really do what' you
really do what' you fucking L cortisone
shots probably I would
yeah at this point I don't know when she
went to the Face store yeah listen in
Beverly house it's been a bad week can I
can I snag another one of mine model 2.2
she she went to Oz on Sunset the
Halloween store and played herself got a
Britney Bear's mask what a buddy what a
sweetheart yeah a sweetheart so I would
cry all the time so they got to get
their makeup done every day cuz they
were not pregnant and I I Was Pregnant
and So I remember having a in the movie
yeah yeah in the movie okay yeah it was
a it was a it was made of bird seed it
was like a like it was a leotard and
they actually put bird seed in it it was
really neat before like they made
pregnant suits and I was like it was
like bird seed in there oh like uh like
like mushy okay and I would cry every
day I'm like I'm just upset Tamara
Tamara Davis Mike D's wife Mike D from
the BC boys and that's that so she'd be
like i' be like I saw I I can't even get
mascara like just cuz I you got no hair
and makeup well I mean they put a little
puff you see a little puff up here that
was a little like that wasn't that was a
puff they that's a sea urchin right they
put a little puff and they put fiely
press on nails just a keep marginalize a
pregnant white trash through and through
so I'd be like what goes well with a
pregnant Bell purple mascara Le Lee
press on nails yep and so you know what
I said then I get to eat a burrito you
know what
then I get to fucking eat the whole time
you assholes so yeah I was I would cry
every day cuz I was I was so young and I
was sad that they look so pretty and I
didn't that was when I learned that I'll
never play the pretty girl when I would
never play The Girl Next Door I've been
told by men that look like jobba the hut
that I will never play the pretty girl
you I have been told you're the
prettiest girl I've ever seen very nice
that's me ever um you're like a super B
we're on the surface of the Sun
currently um this is not what I look
like um but I I just the lighting the
lighting oh I see all the filters yeah
the lighting but um they'll never know I
remember sitting across from this guy
who was an ICM agent and he was like you
know just you're just not pretty enough
to you'll never play the pretty girl she
said it to you and man and I was like
you look like an uncircumcised penis
like if you if we were to bar and you
were just a man right who tried to talk
to me like security would remove you but
because of this building and this
business you're just allowed to tell me
and you're a junior agent that that is
the biggest clam you're not even we're
in a broom closet I mean this isn't even
office you can get away with that here
huh like the fact that you can talk to
me like this and I would outside this
building you're still begging oh of
squeeing my boobs I'll get prettier M
maybe if I sleep more maybe if I go to
the doctor did it all then it's because
he's like I he wanted to probably have
sex with you and that was the only way
he could express it did at all it's
terrible how you feeling this is fing 10
toes baby this is already my favorite
podcast we've ever recorded let's do
this thing wait we haven't been already
going no we are but just checking in cuz
we like hit the ground running oh yeah
I'm I'm hyper so and I just like to like
check in and just like how are you
feeling cuz I always feel like when we
say what our feelings are the feelings
dissipate if you say like I'm scared I'm
less scared I'm nervous so I'm
definitely nervous you you you mean you
think I'm not honest no not in the
slightest I just want to know like I'm
nervous because I'm excited to because I
think you're awesome and I'm like it's
Wai you comments how cool I feel like
we're puppies that finally get to play
puppies or something yeah I like that
thanks for I like that yeah we can go
all deep don't judge if I go deep when
um I was introducing you on the show I
did sing wasting my time all right go no
I have a horrible voice just do it I'll
mouth it if you sing it no you sing it
I'll mouth it well I did it as like I
have such a horrible voice it's like
it's like not even funny it's like sad
it's like heart it's like it's just so
sweet that you love I don't think
you is that
you watch like I put this song on when I
can not unhook from a person and it is
my
Anthem big deal I don't think you
understand um okay so let's get into it
I was watching your IG live the other
night I don't know if you saw me the one
where I was explaining about credit and
earning things and I saw a side of you
on your IG live because like you know
the videos we'll get into all your
videos because I am so riveted by like
you will drop I mean I people say I'm
brave and so when I meet someone that
I'm in awe of their bravery I'm just
like what like it's just so cool to
watch I'm so scared of what I want to
say more you're scared if you revealed
too I mean you'll say because you will
say that in videos You'll Be Like H if I
said anymore you got really think I was
crazy I don't want to die mhm I don't
want to die but anyway going yeah so
then the other night what happened and
the other night and you were trying to
talk to some like you've been really
engaging with people a lot and I was
also kind of just like I had like so
much love in my heart because I like I'm
a standup comic I'm used to having a lot
of feedback I'm used to people writing
crazy shit I'm used to people like
coming for me I'm kind of used to this
like I feel like this kind of new that
you're like really in the trenches on
this and I saw people were saying like
amazing things you know they're like I
love you keep just spit facts and then
someone would say say something shitty
and I would watch you go like thanks
thanks fuck you
any I yeah you were just like shut up
you said shut up you said shut up shut
up I probably said fuck you but I was
just like I'm just like shut up like so
Anno you're just like the pest that
comes through like the parasite that
just kind has to squeeze through like
the mosquito so I was kind of just like
where are you in terms of what to feel
what not to feel cuz I was like a I hope
she develops that skill of just like
water off a duck's back and knowing what
people shit they're just projecting
their own stuff well Amilia and I talk
about this a lot my my friend she says
that they hate themselves apparently yep
and um and you know I don't any want
anybody to hate themselves you know it's
already hard enough so I can't imagine
that someone's just like pop pip piping
off like that because they hate
themselves I feel like they really have
a problem with me and the thing is is
you win some and you lose some you
didn't get famous you're not going to be
loved if you're not loved and hated then
you haven't made it so I'm right there
in a way it hurts sometimes not going to
lie um I've also turned people's um
people have come at me so gnarly and
then I just write them back something
kind and like a little bit smart as well
and they're like oh well you responded
and and they just want attention yeah
they were probably bullied maybe yeah
fair enough yeah you turn off the
comments because I don't want to
oxygenate that playground for the for
the roaches to scatter yeah so my whole
thing is I turn off the comments because
I don't want like the youth I'm very
mindful of like Children and Youth and
Adolescence I don't want them to see cuz
if you repeat something enough people
start to believe it so if they keep
hearing on a thread a drug addict
they're like oh maybe she is maybe we
shouldn't follow her I don't need them
to like buy into like some bullies crap
you know what I mean so that's why I
take the comments out not because I'm
not I'm not scared of it I just it's
negative it's oxy oxygenating negativity
is how I see it I just felt really
bonded to you right away like as this
has been going on because like as
someone who has you know people always
say like are you on adal are you on
cocaine are you on this and I'm always
like I have to be like no I'm not and
then I get defensive and I'm like maybe
they're like well you just talk so fast
and you think so fast I'm like maybe you
think too slow maybe you talk too slow I
don't have time to sit around and wait
for you to fucking think your next
thought like if maybe just think at
different speed rapid yeah why am I the
one that's pathologized just because I
think quickly or when someone I was
talking to someone about this the other
day and I was like people will be like
are you high and I'm like and so you
kind of Dum yourself down like I'm just
chilling and then maybe you're on Xanax
and all the while you're like I want I
want to talk maybe I'm not on adol maybe
you're on oxycoton like cuz who I don't
move through life trying to figure out
what drugs people are on that's that's
what people on drugs
do so you're calling yourself out dude
and you're making me feel like I'm crazy
the gaslighting of it and I was talking
to um that's funny someone about this
the other day when I was like now people
like are you high like if I'm talking
about something that's like a conspir
and I'm like maybe I just said something
original interesting and it just doesn't
sit well you just showed me your
limitations for creativ Your Capacity
yeah your capacity is not my your
threshold your bandwidth isn't my
bandwidth it's not drugs and then every
time I did think like oh she must be on
something not in a negative way like not
I was prescribed Aderall to sleep like I
actually look at you and I'm like she
could use some arerol me well no because
it it calms your brain if you have a
hyperactive like Western medicine I
don't like big Pharma my mom had
migraines in the 80s they didn't know
what those were and though I grew up in
a trailer park home um I never had soda
I never had whoow ad or Tylenol never
had medicine like I had kefir for milk
carab for chocolate so I would sneak
over to Kelly himberger trailer she was
one trailer down I'd get I would get
Fruity Pebbles there I would get a
soda drugs if You' never taken them like
swing my mom's like what what's going on
nothing nothing at all I just had a bowl
of Fruity Pebbles you guys like I'm not
on drugs I just had some Fruity Pebbles
sorry it was I was a bad girl you know
you know what they say they say giving
birth is the equivalent to running a
marathon but but what about being
pregnant and building a company from
scratch also whist taking on the
multivitamin aisle wild that is the
story of rituals founder cat Schneider
who started ritual because she couldn't
find a prenatal that she could trust now
ritual we'll get into you know I've used
ritual for a while my doctor actually
recommended the ritual prenatal and I
was like what I
already I already work with them how did
you know doc cuz prenatals are shady as
hell let's just be honest they all look
like they were made by the same people
who did the 5H Hour Energy drink or
something you look at the ingredients it
says red number five why am I why am I
pumping that into my bloodstream I I've
been using ritual probiotics and the
multivitamin for years you know this
about me why do you think I look so
luminous so it was a new newb brainer I
it did give me a new
brain when it comes to
no-brainer you think of me
first
trademark no
brains it was a no-brainer to use their
prenatal vitamin for I got to I got to
get vitamins of this tiny vampire inside
my belly who on a daily basis tries to
eat my bones I already know I probably
have Round Up In My Blood I grew up
drinking from a hose with baby powder
being sprinkled all over me so I can't
afford to take any more risks with my
health I'm already on my ninth life so I
love ritual prenatal this vitamin is
made traceable with vegan bioavailable
and clinically studied key nutrients for
before and during pregnancy high quality
formulation with nature identical
choline and clinically studied
methylated folate which we talked about
this with Kashif Khan last week on the
podcast if it's not methylated it's not
even absorbing your dorks so this
supports a baby's neural tube
development before and during pregnancy
we don't want our baby to have no brains
like me 350 milligrams of vegan
sustainably sourced omega-3 DHA to
support the baby's brain development
during pregnancy see if I had brains in
my head I would have waited to say that
till after this line non-GMO project
verified gluten-free and major
allergen-free and vegan why are you
going to settle for a multivitamin
you're not 100% sure about that would be
crazy mom brain isn't even an excuse
ritual was literally built on trust so
you know it is the real deal ritual is
offering my listeners 30% off during
your first month visit ritual.com
Whitney to start
ritual or add essential for women
prenatal to your subscription today so
as you guys might have heard a couple
episodes ago I took the sneak peek
gender test to find out what the gender
of my baby is and I'm going to reveal it
today it's just look I know people are
like I want to be surprised I want to
know the gender of my baby as early as
possible I feel like there will be
enough
surprises on the day I have a child as
in both my holes might turn into one
hole I might be surprised and find out
who the father is the day that I give
birth I and I just like I want to know
the gender I I don't know why this would
ever seem like a hot take I need to get
ahead on painting the nursery and I want
to start buying baby clothes and little
baby like shoes and I just I'm a hoarder
and you guys know this about me and I
can't hoard for my baby if I don't know
the gender yet so thank you sneak peek
cuz sneak peek lets you know the gender
of your baby months earlier than an
ultrasound it is possible to know at 6
weeks
99.9% accuracy sneak peek is the safest
earliest most accurate way to learn your
baby's gender at 6 weeks into pregnancy
you don't have to go to the office you
don't have to make an appointment as you
saw in you know a couple episodes ago
when I took the test you do it at home
super super easy you mail it in and the
second it gets to the lab they are going
to send you the gender of your baby the
test is trusted by over 1 million OBGYNs
and moms mail it back in the prepaid
package and you're going to get the
results the same day I say same day it
arrives at the sneak peek Labs the shelf
life is good for a year so buy it now
with the discount and use it later if
you want also it can be the perfect gift
for a loved one who is expecting to find
out the gender of their baby so 5 days
ago I did the test I sent it in now I
have the results they're on my phone and
I'm going to check them right now
live on the show okay I'm gonna hold it
up to the camera first before I look at
it hold
on do you guys see it do you see a pat
mhm yeah congratulations I knew it I can
I tell you something I okay I Okay so so
I knew I okay I didn't know it was going
to be a boy oh my God it's a
boy okay I I guess on some level I felt
because everyone says to me they're like
you're such a boy mom like you're going
to be a boy mom like I don't know I just
that's so crazy but it's also weird
because I do have an entire Word
document of girl name so maybe I didn't
know that is so crazy it just tells you
right there look XY chromosomes male
gender
boy see this is a it's kind of a relief
if I'm going to be honest
because I'm excited to have a boy cuz
this way I'll just get my house
destroyed instead of my entire psyche
you know what my podcast Studio should
just be the nursery it's already blue
this is me this is why I wanted a boy I
wouldn't be able to repurpose my podcast
Studio into a nursery it basically looks
like one looks like a very spooky
haunted Nursery with all these like
weird ass toys and
crystals boy Mom it is
right now sneak peek is offering my
listeners up to $20 off just go to sneak
peek test.com and use my code Whitney to
save up to $20 today that's sneak peek
test.com that's s NE a k p k
test.com and save $20 today go find out
the gender of your baby or buy a couple
of them and have them standing by for
when you get Pros you got them ready and
waiting oh God but there's no boy names
that go well with Cummings but then I go
back and and there's a reason like I
just never you know I love healthy food
and and um and my mom they didn't know
what those were so she went to like
Weare Ohi all the um um clinics that
were healthy like a weat grass Clinic um
gerson's in Mexico all the like all the
all the ones that people get killed for
like like Dr subie yeah like real real
cures so basically I grew up um around
all that believe it or not so it's kind
of interesting because I feel like so
many people right now something like
that I probably could use some like
proper medicine well no no no it's like
for me I my whatever OCD add I think if
you're thinking too quickly and it's
inconvenient for other people they want
to put you to sleep you know they want
you know I ended up going on Pro I'm off
everything now but I went on proac and
because I would be on these Loops like
I'd get obsessed with things I'd find
something you know I'd be like yeah
people like to call me I'm a bipolar or
something like that and I'm like it's
funny because I've played a lot of
bipolar characters where I've actually
had to study it where I go deep into my
studies we're talking talking a real
manic depressant we're talking manic is
like they walk down the street naked
they don't remember what they've done
have sex with like 90 trillion
people and I mean we're talk and then
then calibrate and go back and then yeah
that was my manic that's that's not
what's happening to me and know you said
it very elegantly one day you were like
you know on social media I'm only
presenting what I want you to see you
know what I mean so it's like it's not
interesting to film when I'm just
chilling on my couch doing nothing
remember what the story I told you the
other day when um remember I tried to be
the squeaky will that got oiled on
oranges the New Black and no one knows
this story but do you remember what I
told you y or did I sh shall I she you
think I'm going to get in the way of
this so one fine day it was a one fine
day and um it it just to speak on that
was um I noticed that the squeaky whe
got oiled and we're talking like the
other gals like the more they bitched
the more they got and I'm just one of
those people that I show up to set I go
to my dressing room and I'm like where
do I need to be cuz I'm here to work and
I want to go home to be honest it's a
job and the the roles that you play I
always like how is she it they seem so
emotionally training tort torture and
and it became harder and harder to do
that and um so one so I so I showed up
to set one day is a bad mood I found out
that my boyfriend and my friend had sex
and so all night night long she put me
through we did we didn't we did we did
and it was all night long a pure torture
to where I didn't sleep and then my call
time came so I show up to set and I've
got my hood up per usual I always have
my hood up CU I'm self-conscious of my
hair so that's why I always have my hood
up it's growing back though but I was
walking down the thing and then a couple
co-stars were like hey Taran and hey hey
just went right to my dressing room
didn't cause any problems but two of the
gals went and snitched on me something's
wrong with tering they went right to the
producers and the um and the
showrunner and um and I knew they
somehow I knew they' done that except
when I went to hair there was something
fishy everyone was kind of like
Whispering around me I'm like I already
had a bad day I don't like now I'm just
hypervigilant paranoid if you will I get
onset and I'm pissed because they called
me in way too early too and I had a bad
night and I it was like take two and I
just went pent Tuck's dead and I flipped
the whole set off and they rushed me to
Silver Springs mental institution
because I guess I said I'm going to kill
myself and I'm like oh I didn't really
mean it I was just having a bad day but
I guess you can't say that so Pence
Kentucky's not you you didn't say Taran
Manning is gonna kill herself exactly
but all the squeaky Wheels can get oiled
but the minute I I went off it was a
real problem and I got taken to
Pennsylvania in a nice black car they
took me I'm like oh and I got thrown
into a room they took off my shoelaces
I'm like I don't want to die I was just
mad it it was wild you
know how much do you think the roles
that you have played informs people's
impression of you and makes them biased
of the way that you are as parents the
most it's like you've been punished for
being such a great actress that we
believe you're so believable in your
roles that we've decided you must be
this person it's funny you say that
because I always talk about Schiller's
list is it Ray fine that one like an
Oscar for playing a Nazi but I play
Karen and I'm fucking cancelled I'm like
but I just was hired to be a dick and
it's fun and I went all the way and I
before on action I'd say I'm sorry in
advance for what I'm going to say cuz I
don't know if fucking know what I'm
gonna say because I just go elsewhere
and I was the most racist piece of
living shit on the planet because I was
hired to do that but then all my black
friends would hug me dude that was
amazing they know they know my heart and
you're also stepping into a role that is
Shining Light on actual racism you know
what I mean it's like you're actually
doing something that I try to show that
people like that can hurt people's lives
the people that are snitchy and talk
shit can actually harm someone's life by
just one phone call or one complaint do
you feel like that movie and everything
that's happened in the last couple
months do you think they worked together
to sort of or you you think that's what
got you canceled you said um I well I
was cancelled the day that I held up um
so before I realized what was happening
in America cuz I didn't grow up in a
political family member I grew up in in
a trailer park my mom said don't vote or
you'll have to go to jury
duty that is a life hack had I known
that and I was like okay so I don't vote
and I think that most actors knew that
like I don't wear the sticker I voted
and I'm sorry but I'm not I don't know
whenever I see a famous actor wearing
that sticker I'm like oh God you voted
God damn it so I started to realize that
you know what I should probably learn
more about like the um legislation
within my state and then but as far as
the president the leader of the Free
World
white
men that can't run an entire country
like that there's a lot more going on
there if you really think that one
person can run an entire it's just that
that doesn't add up to me so anyway so I
don't speak on stuff like that but one
fine day I saw Trump hold up the Bible
and you know how I feel about the Lord I
do so I'm like I think the leader of the
Free World found God that was it that
was the beginning of the cancellation
that I was a trump supporter and all the
girls from Orange they they all blocked
me all my friends from the show blocked
me and I was like Lori Petty she always
comes down on me Lori Petty she comes
down on me all the time she tricked me
again last night um she said how are you
talked for like 30 minutes and then she
said I just can't believe you I'm like
what why can't you believe I think we're
having a great great talk I'm like well
what is it can't believe what can't
believe what you posted you should take
that down immediately I'm like what take
down
what Trump and I was like oh what's
wrong with it I didn't know I didn't
know I didn't know that people truly
hated this man and it would literally
change my life changed the trajectory of
my life then I was ashamed for a long
time then I said you know what f it he's
a punk rocker and I like it meaning I
don't know if he's the one but I like
the way he rocks I was probably
concurrently at the same time you were
going through this running the Roseanne
reboot and watching this woman who you
know just Legend icon her entire Legacy
destroyed because she basically said
like she was making very cogent
arguments about it she was like stop
looking at Trump forget about Trump was
that one tweet it was like better the
monkey well there was that but she was
always a jokester yeah that it's
like wait wait wait what I say something
no you're just it's so actually it's
just more you're so refreshing you're
such a the fresh air is that not the one
that just went ahead and put the nail
that's it that's it it's nervous
laughter because you you sorry about
that you are in this I'm we're all
jealous because you're in this place
right now where you're like you're like
fuck it what are you going to do come
for me and you have a free have that no
one else has left and you're just and
that's why it's so I can move to the
middle you know Middle America and I'll
never have to deal with that that pain
again where I'm canceled by another
human being that has skeletons in their
closet too yeah which by the way don't
get me started on the people in
Hollywood that support Trump they just
don't say it it's secret amen okay and
they're all around us by way they're
ubiquitous I mean that's the whole thing
that happen thank you um what does it
mean here's the other thing about you is
you're so funny I was talking I asked
her like what was that word you just
said Remember on the phone I'm like what
does that mean that's what I said I was
like she's so fucking smart and quick
but I love when someone doesn't know
something they go what does that mean
like you're just the best of I'm a
sponge I feel like I'm a child reborn
again I feel like my mind was stifled at
some point like locked up like in like a
like in a like locked and then suddenly
it was like your brain being locked up
did that have anything to do with
coinciding with getting famous or
getting starting in Hollywood or
anything um the thing is is that I was
studying acting for so long that my
acting teacher told me never to even
start till I was 19 and I was like and I
was in class with Kirsten dun Le
Sobieski Erica Christensen Evan Evan
Rachel um meres McNab like all gals
before they made it so I was amongst
girls that would end up being and guys
boys too that would end up being great
actors that you know if you think about
it they're all very good sincere actors
you know maybe as people questionable
but you know just but he would never
sorry listen sorry I just I just listen
this it's very rare to meet someone that
is like sorry that again more Burn It
Down syr is there AIC I say too like you
can't say it like he's a great actor
person like so unnecessary but like to
me it's necessary well the the worst
part about it is like let's let's talk
about a movie called crazy beautiful I
was in and my co-star was Kirsten Dunst
and I know that there's certain people
that know her or great gal listen but
she would pretend to be my friend
because we were friends in it and I'd
feel like oh I think she might actually
like me oh God Story of My Life hon
Story of My Life and then she go to her
trailer and she won't come out I'd be
like hello I thought we were Pals nope
it was all for show so I learned how to
be like oh I can play a friend too and
then go to my trailer but no one comes
looking for me the way I went looking
for her cuz like she grew up in a
trailer park that's her home we leave
her in there she did Oh Me Oh yeah I'm
like I'm just at home here just just
sleeping in there yeah I love trailers
to be honest RVs they're they're it's
cozy especially when the rain falls it's
like it hit the noise is really
when you said I believe it was that
movie Crazy Beautiful when you did the
Press tour you said that you know I come
from a trailer park I grew up poor
Section 8 housing so they didn't pay me
yeah yep there's one like a big regret
that I as observing and some of that you
know I'm surveillancing why how come she
came up after me how
come how what what is this about you
know what I mean I was just really
trying to like um understand it and
process it was my the biggest mistake
was the first time I did press in in a
magazine actually um you know in writing
as I I told the truth about who where I
came from and who I am and I've been
treated like that ever since and that's
basically I grew up in a in Section 8
housing in Tucson Arizona before the
trailer park I lived in Ebro Section 8
housing my mom put me in kindergarten
when I was only four because she
couldn't afford daycare anymore and she
loves to tell the story um when she did
that so basically it's a little early to
go into kindergarten so I was four years
old and she bought me my backpack and my
little outfit and I went to the bus stop
for all the other kids but we're talking
Melting Pot of kids by the way black you
know Mexican white trash Galore um and
but and she's like all right honey you
can do it what's your phone number and I
repeated it okay what's your address I
repeated it and she said all right and
the bus pulled up and she said I walked
with my shoulders back and I never
looked back and I got on the bus she
thought I might look over nothing and
nope I was like you did this to me I'm
going all in I think that's the day my
mind broke I was like oh boy and then
she held me back in first grade
horrified I was so pissed so then in
eighth grade I had a car because I was
the oldest eighth grader up in that
joint and I had a whip I'm like oh shit
let's do this thing yeah
so so it kind of backfired but she let
me start driving at 13 my mom let me
take the car all around I love to drive
my dad taught me how to drive that was
the last thing he ever taught me was how
to drive stick shift change a tire but
Jack it up with the tools that were in
the trunk and then he killed himself one
year later but that's one of the last
things we ever did together I burned his
clutch out but the whole the break I
knew I mean everything that was the last
thing we did because I was hyper he
called my mom like what do I do with her
she's because I was growing boobies and
pubic hairs I didn't want to leave
California listen I was boy crazy I was
like I got to go to Dad's this summer oh
no so apparently pubes everywhere got
Pub little booies I was triple
aier I want I wanted to meet some some
boys I was like no way I got to go so I
drove my dad nutty and he's like Sharon
what do I do with her I don't know I
don't know Bill you know I don't know
what to say so he taught me how to drive
tell me how to drive because that got
some energy out you know because I've
always been like this and you're only
child no I have a brother okay oh that's
right you talk
about work together um do you feel like
you always got this feedback like you
know for me by the time I started
getting public feedback from people I
guess I was like I've always been told
I'm manic and I'm hyper and I'm over
ambitious and I you know have tourettes
and I say the thing I'm not supposed to
say and I'm problematic like I've always
got this even when I was like a kid you
march to the beat of your own drum yeah
always the first thing I ever read on
the internet was like when the when
computers first came out my brother's a
real techie so the very first thing I
ever read was she's got she's got her
mouth is like a butthole it looks like a
butthole like a like like an anus or too
big for her mouth as you would say a
balloon KN B there you go that's that's
to make that's to make it a little
easier to accept that I have a butthole
mouth so wow the the them and that
didn't set me off in the right
direction I was like yeah but by the way
what I'll say is that person saying your
mouth looks like a butthole my tongue I
had a speech impediment I want to talk
about that that I've gotten you can
still hear it a little bit me too me too
same you do yeah i' I've had for a long
time so we'll cut paddle cut stuff out I
do when I'm anxious and like nervous it
gets worse because that was and I'm
we're not we're coming back to the
balloon knot but don't think we're just
gonna blow past that um one two open
your balloon knot for five in your
ball I'm just saying that person saying
that your mouth looks like a butthole
says more about what his butthole looks
like than anything else yeah last I
studied yeah it's like straight like
straight up like just like so then I got
a bunch of collagen in my lips I was
like yeah you know what and so trying to
get like lip injections and in a but
hole mouth you can't really make a you
can't make you can't make lips all right
so then I got a ginormous like C sore I
was like oh no what have I done cuz it
was all the trauma with the syringes you
can't make lips wait now what well that
worked that fucking worked
huh like a Banger like from here to here
I was like what happened where did you
where did you go hole exactly where did
you get it some doctor I I paid the last
was like 3,000 something or other
dollars too Jesus yeah and he just and
then they squeeze I think it was all a
squeeze and I'm like ah it already hurts
so
bad it hurts so bad then they just went
let
up listen I back down you also something
else about you that just kills me is you
kind of every now and then talk like a
man from the 30s oh yeah I I told you I
I told you about my story it's just like
he wouldn't let up I tell y I'm like
wait what is she channeling period
period that one period my friend Phil
goes he goes your mom want to said that
too lot when I when I end a s be like
period like I'll just be like he's like
your mom said that too I'm like no no
one Noe my mom said I marched the beat
it actually what my mom said all the
time is I didn't have you you just came
through me you and I'd be like okay well
who had me I know I don't own you you
just came through me that was her
favorite thing to say all my childhood
just cuz you were so eccentric and just
so your own I don't I don't own you you
just came through me I asked people
people like maybe she wanted you to be
independent I think she was trying to
tell you you were adoped yeah do it mean
you just don't love me can you just say
it loud and
proud I don't know what it means it's
very deep for like a 5-year-old like
that was a lot to comprehend did you
feel like you had to work hard for
attention did that I was obsessed with
her I tortured her I just wanted her her
attention so bad I'd cry every time she
tucked me in with her shoes still on her
tennis shoes I'd be where you going I
knew she was leaving for to run errands
because Kellen is older my brother so
that was her thing so she had to take
her shoes off so I would go to sleep
because we slept in the same
bed uh growing up so my brother always
got the bedroom and we slept together
it's fine I would never have it any
other way but I knew she was leaving and
that would just make me so sad I'm just
fascinated by just sort of like what
makes a performer especially with where
you come from and where you got well
there's a great story that when my mom
allegedly left my dad was in the middle
of the night I was two months old I
guess he threw me down to the ground and
um and I didn't
go I I went silent okay so it's like he
threw me just to get a rise and my mom
went to like this is this is all leged I
don't remember
um and then she went to grab me stop he
stopped me or stopped my mom and Kellen
and uh and I was alive clearly it's a
little frontal L damage here and there
been dropped on my head a few times um
my grandma also dropped me on my head
she she had me one of those like
carriers at the end of like a Target
yeah a sail and
then like it fell off like a beach bag
straight down like that L shit okay so
it's all coming together it's all coming
together so basically apparently my mom
dipped in the middle of the night and
she drove from Virginia to Arizona and
um and on on her way she was you know
she was a single woman um you know I was
still nursing and she was a woman in
Despair and so she was in New Mexico and
she pulled over I guess this is the
story and a lady beckoned her and come
on come on ma'am I see you you look
thirsty she saw a young mom with two
children and she was a psychic and my
mom doesn't like psychic she doesn't
like anything like that so she just
couldn't believe where she ended up and
and the woman said cuz remember there
was a baby and then her son she goes one
of your children's going to be a
worldwide renowned star that people are
going to love and my mom loves to tell
me this I always thought it would be
your
brother what is it with moms sorry Mom
why can't they just let us have it why
can't they just let us have it there's a
quote I love that's why I named him
Kellen William Manny he was an author
well I'm sorry you name you Taran
there's a saying in the 12 star program
I'm in that's uh like your mom uniquely
knows how to push your buttons because
she installed them like she knows
exactly where to go and there she's no
fool that lady is very smart I really my
mom's very intelligent very do you still
talk to her I mean you guys tou yeah
it's just a we just just have a tough
time together we don't I don't fight
with her no way she's older I would
never it's just that we just fire
differently mhm that's really
interesting and let me but I love her so
much here we go buy optimizers you guys
I got it we're talking about it lately I
have been lying awake at night 4 hours
physically exhausted trying to fall
asleep you've probably seen the weird
Instagram posts but I I just I cannot
fall asleep I I mean my mind has been so
wired cuz I'm pregnant I've got acid
reflux we're at War life is a nightmare
I'm pregnant and on dating apps it's
there's a lot of things to be worried
about right now and then because I can't
sleep I'll go on my phone and be like I
can't sleep then I'll see five other
nightmares that keep me up even longer
and it's like this vicious cycle that I
can't break but guess what broke
it magnesium saved the day ever since I
started magnesium Breakthrough by bu
optimizers to my nightly routine I have
been able to quiet my Bonkers mind and I
sleep like a dead person sometimes I
think I'm dead I sleep 8 hours I've been
sleeping 8 hours I wake up refreshed
look at me I already look younger than
the baby growing inside me I I actually
don't even have to take a nap every day
anymore now that I've been taking bi
optimizers it it it was kind of weirding
people out that at like 3 I'd be like I
need to retire to my chamber for my
daily nap like I'm excited to have a
baby but I don't want to have the same
sleep schedule as him okay it's a little
creepy as an adult so this is a game
changer unlike other magnesium
supplements that might be giving you one
to two forms of magnesium magnesium
breakthrough contains all seven
forms it's genius seven forms of
magnesium designed to help calm your
mind help you fall asleep stay asleep
and wake up refreshed over 75% of the
population is magnesium deficiency that
is wild what most people don't know is
that even if they're taking magnesium
supplements they're still deficient
because they're not getting all seven
forms so magnesium breakthrough it's the
ultimate way to give your body all seven
forms in One supplement in addition to
experience relax sleep magnesium
breakthrough also helps improve
digestion support muscle I was going to
say Discovery you might discover some
muscles you don't have also Muscle
Recovery it it supports healthy bone
density most magnesium supplements are
proven to be ineffective again because
they only contain one to two forms of
magnesium that's a scam no more snake
oil magnesium breakthrough contains all
seven key forms of magnesium to help you
have a relaxed response to stressful
situations don't miss out on the most
relaxing sleep ever with magnesium
breakthrough for an exclusive offer for
my listeners go to mag breakthrough.com
Whitney and use the promo code Whitney
it's right here I've got it right by my
bed in the drawer with the you know what
use promo code Whitney during checkout
save 10% for an exclusive offer for my
listeners go to mag breakthrough.com
Whitney do it now your body and your
brain will thank you again that's mag
breakthrough.com Whitney promo code
Whitney to save 10
perent so when I started podcasting I
don't I don't I don't think I knew this
would go well I didn't realize that
women talking for three hours was like a
lucrative business you know and so I
wasn't I wasn't thinking in terms of
merch I wasn't thinking in terms of an
online store but now I'm an
entrepreneurial genius I am selling my
merch I sell my book it's called I'm
fine and other lies it's right behind me
it is so easy okay because I use Shopify
Shopify is the global Commerce platform
that helps you sell at every stage of
your business from the launch your
online shop stage to the first real life
store stage all the way to the did we
just hit a million orders stage Shopify
is there to help you grow whether you're
selling scented soap or offering outdoor
outfits Shopify helps you sell
everywhere from their all-in-one
e-commerce platform to their inperson
POS system wherever and whatever you're
selling Shopify has got you covered
Shopify helps you turn browsers into
buyers with the internet's best
converting checkout 36% better on
average compared to other leading
Commerce platforms look I was not doing
well with being an entrepreneur because
I don't like a soulless approach I I
want to be able to like update people on
when the orders will be delivered I like
to send a personalized note saying like
don't worry it's coming and like
thanking them for buying but Shopify
makes it super easy so I'm not
constantly having to do updates on
social media because I get insecure like
if I don't get a package that I order I
start freaking out and I just can now
email straight to the customer and which
just helped me feel less like I was like
Shilling things you and more I wanted to
feel like a meet and greet after a
standup show where I get to like like
here's the size you wanted thanks for
buying it like and Shopify helps you do
that so like what I love about Shopify
is how easy they make it to connect with
the buyers look I'm not a dumb person
but running a business is a spooky
nightmare okay you got the ins and outs
you got the ups and the Downs that's not
where I shine okay and there's there's a
lot of numbers and we all know I'm
dyslexic shop Shopify gives you
everything you need to take control and
take your business to the next level it
helps you track your orders see who
bought what and what size so you know
what to reorder you know what's popular
you get to see where the the orders are
located like what part of the country so
then you can start like customizing your
merch to the people that like it the
most you can even send automatic email
to the person buying it that's my
favorite it's all in one place it is so
easy even a comedian can use it Shopify
Powers 10% of all e Commerce in the
United States and Shopify is the global
force behind all birds rothy which by
the way wearing today check that out and
Brook linen and millions of other
entrepreneurs of every size across 175
countries plus shopify's award-winning
help is there to support your success
every step of the way because businesses
that grow grow with Shopify sign up for
$1 per month trial period at shopify.com
Whitney all lowercase go to shopify.com
Whitney now to grow your business no
matter what state in shopify.com
Whitney so back to the but holes so I
feel like there's a theme Here We I was
dying laughing with you on the phone
because you know the because the the
video that came out you talk about
buttholes and my favorite part about it
it wasn't me I was cloned I swear it was
AI it wasn't me listen this shit's real
I watching that video I was horrified
only cuz I was like that would have been
me that's me that is me that is I am two
Sharday away from making that video if I
knew my Tik Tok password I would have
already done this okay I mean dude I was
like I was just like oh God I gotta take
Tik Tok off my phone I was not myself I
I that is just so out of character in a
way all of it the whole shebang the
whole the whole the whole thing and um
what what was going on with your DMs
after that I mean it
feels I was like that all anyone could
talk about is like every guy knows did
you see the thing about the the the Lick
in the butthole did you see like I'll
tell you I've never made more friends in
my
life I got friends up I got friends up
the wo listen I can't keep up invited
every party Under the Sun you want to be
on my list let's
go I beat you because of
it listen I'm with Whitney CS because of
it listen if I could do it all over I'd
make it better
I don't know what to
say listen this guy wasn't he wasn't you
know he wasn't all bad I don't just fall
for anybody he he was rad and he's a
musician and I fall for that and um well
his wife allowed us to hang out often so
it was confusing and then also I was
helping him like Get over his um
diabetes and his I mean I was I make I
like I'm a really good like cook and
Chef and I make like vegan and healthy
food very healthy and he his diabetes
his levels were going down I was saving
his life he had a grand um stroke or a
grand what's it like a proper heart
attack where basically like dusted and
yeah so I was he was losing that a gave
him a heart attack no this was then
before okay the more he slimmed down I
was like maybe I can you can actually
get it may had you have you
showered have your
shower well I mean when you can't when
the boner isn't going to happen you got
to get you got to do something listen I
got needs
too I'm to throw I got needs I'm me they
going to throw lady I'm not sure which
but the number I I don't know what to
say the number of people that send that
to be men guys that was why did they
send that well they because they'd be
like hey this is crazy and i' like
watching the the butle thing that's
that's crazy right like girl I mean
doing that that's what listen I'm a
Scorpio that's our ayous
Zone nothing new here everybody listen
it was like every what a big deal every
man was using it as an opportunity to
float the idea no one was like this is
what do you say guys are like this is
like crazy right like uh like
girl honey we've been married 25 years
listen have you ever thought that maybe
one fine day if I showered really good
and I put on some Marvin
game yeah I can use my butthole mouth
kiss your butthole but maybe that's
where it
started maybe I just thought it belong
you want to see if you really your mouth
my brother told me that I was an anal
baby that I was born out of the anus it
probably started there that's the truth
it's not he would embarrass me your mom
was trying to say you came right through
me cry where was I was Bor out the b
king yep sure were you
asshole I'm like and then I finally
figured out one day that I was born out
not the urethra cuz then I thought it
was the urethra so I just went all
around the all around and back again not
the tank no a Tain my
problem that I was born out of the
vagina it turns out and that I was a
normal baby so I felt better about that
yeah yeah yeah yeah but yeah there's
been a whole thing about but holes and
this and that but listen it was fun all
right I'm not going to lie and I feel
bad because he didn't deserve that you
know what I mean like you know what I
even know what I was thinking yeah that
was pretty bad but I did yeah I didn't I
didn't realize it I don't even know I
don't remember what I said this is
what's so crazy is like I can drink like
two drinks for me is not you know like
so the fact that that two drinks and in
that I couldn't even stand and I don't
know if it was that like I told you like
being on the boat the vertigo or
something but I mean we're talking bamby
like weak weak in and knes just like do
you think he roofied his butthole I
don't know I don't know what happened I
only know is had a shitload of cash on
me to buy the boat I want to the boat I
wanted to sail away and never come back
you can't buy the murder weapon of the
man huh men buy boats to get rid of
their mistress oh yeah I haven't you
followed what the presidents are doing
with their chefs oh oh boy let not let's
not let's not but so you the one that
really runs the country any moving
forward but you think something
definitely was like slipped in something
was off I wouldn't say that cuz it's
fair to say that some people do get
seasick a little bit and we were we end
taking the boat out to seea and a couple
they were very sweet and um we went to
this restaurant that was we docked on
the side and um we went to eat have a
drink and have like we all got like
french fries just we had like a big
plate of french fries and but there was
all these like cuties there there was
like I love skateboarders and like
Surfers like that's shit so I was like
you like to come back here CTE cuz I
mean he the dude I was like you know
doing that with like he could never been
mine so I still looking around I've been
single for a long time so I was looking
at all these Cutie Pies and they were
looking at me and some people recognized
me and they were kind of geeking out a
little bit and I wondered if it was
maybe one of the bartenders so my friend
Emily said to me I go but why would
someone do that to me knowing that I was
with a group and I was going to leave
she had two great points she said one
cuz maybe you wouldn't leave or two they
wanted to watch you like they wanted
some people get off on watching you know
somebody like struggle and look like
she's messed up on something so but it
didn't really hit me until we got back
in the dingy and then we went to the
boat and then we went back on the boat
and then remember I told you I went up
to the front so I could like lay out and
really be like do I want to buy this
boat I love the boat and he didn't come
to the forward and like chill with me
he's just
talking wouldn't stop talking and I'm
trying to relax and all I could hear
just he just over talked and I remember
then I walked down the side I was like
can you just shut the f up you just
don't stop talking and and and I just
something came over me and I was I want
to go home I want I gotta get out of
here and I it was sudden and that was it
and that was the end of us forever right
there I don't you know because I
realized what am I doing like can't have
you you're married it's like something I
finally like came to you know it's like
someone that just like the perfect storm
of like concentric things like you had
an epiphany it also drives me nuts when
people recognize you like bartenders
they're like let me send more drinks or
they make your your drink stronger cuz
they're like a fan of yours like if you
like me you're not going to send me
extra shit so that I can like humiliate
myself there was yeah maybe there was
that or they you know because there was
this group of dudes that they kept like
looking but then they ended up talking
to him because he's pretty rad you know
this dude or that so he was they were
talking remember he never stops talking
so so I fired I don't even know what I
said I won't watch it I won't watch them
bad things like that about myself
because that to me is like oxygenating
time in my life that isn't healthy and
then when now it's all over the inter K
Teran the first thing that comes up it's
like would you look at that so I was
embarrassed I died no I think it's
interesting because no one that I've
talked to like like look I'm Comics like
all my people are Comics like we all we
do that like once a week you know what I
mean we just don't have as many
followers so you have more followers I
didn't even know people even knew I
existed anymore it was shocking I didn't
know that certain press people were
watching or yeah I didn't I didn't know
well I think you are more relevant than
you think I think everyone has a little
bit of dysmorphia over how famous they
are and you're probably healthfully not
like constantly checking you know but I
think that right now we're at a time
where it's become a sport to pounce on
someone making a mistake or having a
hard time in their life and we sort of
um you I mean look this is something
that you know I try to put in
perspective because or else I'll just
get too depressed about Humanity I mean
there used to be the Town Square you go
watch people be humiliated like there's
something in our sort of tribal DNA that
we get off on shaming people watching
people get shamed whether it's you know
our primordial need to see what's
acceptable in the tribe and what's not
but these like pylons where people um
you know for sport want to watch someone
get shamed and humiliated it's kind of
like become you know this sick um
Dynamic on the internet and no one that
sent it to me everyone was like do you
know her you know should you reach out
it was more what do you think that is
though just to go back to all that
amazing stuff you said what is that in
our broken existence that wants that
well Mass shaming is like they serve an
important purpose you know it's like
they say um the reason that public
speaking is so terrifying you know stand
up so terrifying because on a primordial
level like our brain thinks that we're
being put on trial by the tribe okay you
know like you're having to make your
case in front of the tribe like say you
you know when someone abused a child
they like make your Cas and they all
have rocks and they're ready to kill you
you know so it's like when you're
watching public shaming it's your way to
kind of collect data over what's
acceptable you know what side to be on
and how to get protection from the tribe
you know so it's like what I see which I
um really pisses me off to be inelegant
about it is when people are like well
she's this and she's this and I'm like
stop pretending like you haven't done
that stop pretending like you don't make
mistakes stop pretending like you're
perfect we should all be jumping to her
and protecting her and going like you
already just went through some rough
shit let's protect her so that it
doesn't get worse you're already going
through something right now you're
already whatever was put in your drink
or you know you obviously your heart was
hurting like why aren't we jumping on
her instead of mass shaming her um it's
okay you know I know I know it's okay
but it changed my life well that's my
I'm curious because then after that
you're go oh this is going to end in
someone going to you know rehab or going
to end poorly and then I see you rise
like a fucking Phoenix From the Ashes
the most resilient bitch I've ever seen
being like all right now I have you guys
are really fucked now because now I have
nothing to lose and I'm going to drop
all these facts and everyone's like I
guess this is what it takes in Hollywood
for someone to be able to tell the truth
or be brave enough to talk about sort of
the injustices and the financial abuse
and maybe it had to come to this for you
to detach from the Naple right of
Hollywood right I don't know you know
it's it's it's wild um so so I I I
grapple with that because it's like it's
like I don't think God would want me to
to to hurt that bad right but sometimes
he's got to just uh he knows what he's
doing and um and i' I've loved him for a
long time my the god of my understanding
um which I completely respect about you
know you know everybody's understanding
of the Lord or or God creator the
universe like that's that's to each in
their own you know so um if that's what
he did to
like to to shred all ego and to shred
you know what I was trying to be which
was like I'm just going to pretend that
I'm I'm a lovely lady cook maybe I'll
get to play surely and not Rose for once
you know like no it's never going to
happen like like I was never going to
get to play I was never going to get the
lead in like a Mulan Rouge or ever get
the lead in like Chicago but though I'm
a trained dancer s you know just just
they just don't see me like that because
of the mistakes I made telling people
where I came from you know um you know
when you when you admit that you're
damaged that's where the Sharks come in
you don't bleed in front of shark so but
at the same time I don't know who did
that to me but all I know is that
something happened where I finally
started to just be me and there's my cup
runneth over like I've been wanting to
just blurt out and rant there's a lot of
opposing opinions you need to stop doing
that you need to refine your IG you're
not going to work again and I just keep
saying so so I don't I'm down to my last
like $10,000 I never thought I'd be
broke I was rich baby but I'm broke is a
joke but I don't care I don't care
because there's something happening and
I feel it a ruin and I don't know what
it is but I know that I help I know all
the kind things people say on my DM how
I've helped them I made them remember
who they are that yeah there's so much
there's so much good so much positivity
too that I'm like I think I'm on the
right track because what I'm seeing is
authenticity I got two offers the other
day and and I they're not bad either by
the way and I just like the fact that
I'm like hanging on every word like oh
work like the desperation is gone the um
the um the even fear the fear is gone
I'm just like yeah I'll get to that when
I want I don't care anymore and that
feeling is amazing and I don't know how
to teach it but I just want people to
know
that that I don't know that and you seem
like you're having the most fun and I
think that like when you're in fear like
you can't have fun you don't even know
you're so disconnected I me I'm sad by
the way I'm very sad deeply sad but I've
always been sad about that okay no I'm
sad in general like I have a sadness
that that looms over me like I I miss my
dad um I miss my mom I miss my life the
life that I freaking did for this
freaking career I have no husband no
kids like and I have no money like was
it worth it so that's my whole thing to
people it's not because I fell off on
drugs I was never paid people think
we're just Rich nope it was a paid right
ever I was paid I was paid like I was
thrown chunk change but I was like we
like like I was never paid for Hustle
and Flow It's a known thing I was never
paid for the movie that I'm most known
for but I won I won the litigation after
20 years I went for mine so I'm waiting
for that payout because I'm like this
can't keep happening now I've grown up
and I'm like dude I've been treated like
garbage like I wish I would have just
went into the garbage can maybe I'd have
a husband and kids business is crappy
it's not good for everybody do you feel
like you knew that was happening at the
time like when did you realize oh I'm
not getting paid for this cuz sometimes
like oh we'll get you it's I didn't know
because I never came from money that my
first like thousand bucks I was like I'm
rich like I never seen a check with a
thousand never in my life thought I quit
my job I worked at Maurice's burrito
Adventure I said I'm out of here I'm
rich that's I was like yes and then I
was $1,000 like well that went away
quick hey can I have my job back agent
manager five five unle 10 and five like
and then they took so and I was just I
just couldn't believe my eyes and that
was one of the first and then I was
fired so I was hired I was I'm a dancer
and I was hired to play in a movie
called a time for dancing and I got the
I got the role after like nine auditions
with margarite Derek she's one of the
biggest choreographers in
Hollywood I went through the mill it was
me and Jenum Malone and um she gets
cancer in the movie and her hair falls
out so then my character shaves her head
I was shaving my head went all in well
one F we had rehearsals dress rehearsals
a wardrobe we even did one day on the
set and then I was
fired I got a call and it went like this
it was this is how harsh it was and then
I wrote wasted my time it was like this
it was Kelly her was Kelly
Powers hey Taran we're releasing you
from the
movie that was it and I called like a
psycho again because I thought we got
disconnected it was a
landline and yeah they let me go because
they got more money so they hired the
girls from Roswell remember Roswell sh
Applebee and yeah whatever her name is
they they replaced me movie tanked but
they replaced me when they got more
money but the Heartbreak that I felt I
can't talk about your heart falling out
of your butthole I've never felt that
pain I had flowers covering my apartment
all my friends they I was devastated I
mean we're talking that's but I was like
you know what I can fucking sing and
play the guitar suck my t
and basically that's when my music
kicked off because at that point you
would never ever Define me as an actor
like a cow that you can just fire so
I've always rocked as a musician first
that can act but that's not actors to me
they're not
respected correct we're not correct
we're like it's as an actor you're a
puppet you're a disposable puppet
everything you you even when you do
advocate for yourself even if you have
been treated poorly and are trying to
you just it's being dramatic they're
just like they see us as like children
yeah just cows like like just Mo just
like with like a tag in our ear and that
we're replaceable but we're not because
you can't just replace you and get
another you you can't replace me so I
just found another way to sort of like
sect into that I'm more than that and so
it's just sort of built from that that
from that moment forward like feeling
that pain cuz remember I'm a dancer like
I mean we're talking ballet like how you
can't replace me with SH be she's got no
like I can watch like Black Swan and be
like naty Perman has no point I can see
when the double kicks in like I'm no
fool you know I can see it all and it's
like how about you have an actor who can
dance what a concept so I've just felt
like always like just like just just
half half realize from their eyes do you
feel like realize realize realize do you
feel like the music business is was a
little yeah it's pretty garbage business
too right yeah and you've had to chase
around getting paid for like no no we
got paid well for our music okay good
yeah yeah it was just that DreamWorks
went out of business while we were
touring in Japan now they call the
record's done click like the rug was
just pulled out and that was that that
was our first album was just pulled out
and everybody was Upstream to Inner
scope but not boomcat because we were so
much in a deficit because we did get
such a big record deal so yeah they just
didn't want to Upstream us so it was
just another yeah just l a heartbreak
but I keep going and The Cat Came Back
again and again I mean that's the thing
because it is I do feel like you know
they are like oh we can hurt you but
like you come from such a horrible thing
that like what's another ding or like
this person's pain tolerance is so high
maybe like the bandwidth or the
threshold like they would want my adic
Chrome when did you know that being
Christian or believing in God was kind
of a liability in like did was this
recent or was this something you'd
experienced
before cuz I do feel I'll just
as as you're thinking I um I say God I'm
in a 12ep program comfortable with God
but I think that in our business and
this also I think comes from there's a
lot of prejudice against people from the
South Southern Accents and there's a lot
of prejudice of people that believe in
in God they assume that you must be dumb
in Jesus in Jesus you must be dumb even
though they believe in crystals I I you
know what I mean like sort of no offense
um we love crystals I'm just saying that
you know to me it's like the thing you
guys believe in like polyamory like you
know don't come for my belief system you
know as if I'm dumb or backwards or
something like that you know remember
like The Passion of the Christ was very
much sort of like and then yeah he got
like struck by lightning doing I mean
that whole movie was it was like set up
all the
obstacles yeah so just in general like
Christianity and I mean but we were
talking on the phone about like Chris
Pratt's been open about being Christian
hey super Mark Walberg I think if you're
like a hot young proven guy maybe you
can get away with it more but has
definitely gotten shit for it or
definitely has he does you know but he's
like he's basically like up there he's
one of the most known or like revered
actors so I'm happy to hear that yeah
and then yeah Mark wber I think you
moved out of Hollywood I think women
it's already you're dumb and crazy and
now you believe in God you know I don't
know but when did you feel like so
basically I was I was so that's a great
question and and there's a journey it's
hard to like try to sum it all up but I
was born into a religion called the
bahai faith
oh yes the bahai temple there's one in
um WKA in Chicago yeah Evon there'sa and
one in Evon it's beautiful oh St it's
gorgeous I don't know ton about it
though yeah me either okay so basically
like so I grew up like that so I went to
Sunday school so there was always like a
you know a Sunday school moral compass
and all that and um at 18 you have to
like declare it like on paper where you
like sign that you you are an official
bigh and my brother and I both didn't
want to sign um because in the bahai um
it's called the well the thing is is
that there we have the prophets bahah
and Abdul bah and then the Bob and
basically but there's only so much
scripture and then it ends because it's
a newer religion it started in like the
late
1800s so like a sect of Muslim to be
honest and came from the Middle East I'm
like how the heck did CH on Arizona mom
who how the heck do we find this
religion so bizarre you know but but I
was a proud bahai and um and then when I
turned 18 we didn't declare it my
brother and I we just sort of carried on
but I was always a Seeker then I became
a Buddhist I became SGI Nam y so I have
my boots sit on and my gohanon like that
I earn that's Buddhist chanting well at
what age did you start doing that um
that was probably like mid or late 20s
huh was there something specific that
called you to it um just trying to seek
the truth I was seeking everything I I
was hung out with Harry Krishna like
clearly and I love I always wanted to go
to college for religion love like I
don't study my scripts all night I'm
studying religion yeah yeah so that's
just you know what you find yourself
doing so everything kept taking me back
to the Bible and also I kept having to
play Christians because that's because
remember I play stupid people like you
said so well she could be she'll be
hired to play the stupid Jesus and it
was like oh not this again you know I
was horrified this is the truth and I
and I kept playing Christians and
Christians I'm like oh my God this shit
like I judge this the same way like
people consider Christian stupid so I
kept being cast as the stupid person I
always play
well it you do it enough and you keep
studying that book and it it started to
seep in you know when I would read first
of all was a foreign language I would be
like oh God trying to study this get it
right it was so hard and um and then
I'll never forget the day that it just
it's it was like I can't explain it um I
can't explain the feeling that came over
made physical it's like the day that all
the words is like they just turned into
like I don't know I just I could
understand it and and it couldn't stop
turning the page I was like and it was
like the be the best drug that I'd ever
taken like it was like just the tingles
head to toe and head to toe and the
tears and the tears and the tears and
the tears I could think about it now and
I cry I don't know how to explain it but
it's real and um and I you know I wish
that you know he comes tenderly he comes
in his own time and and it's real the
way we describe it is like it's
surrender like the feelingly of I'm not
in charge like I can just trust a bigger
plan like I don't have to be running the
show anymore and it's not about you know
I always say to new people that come
into program like you don't have to
believe in God you just have to believe
you're not God nice and that it's not
about your will and just the idea of
like taking the backpack off like taking
the like you're not in the driver's seat
anymore just being able to be a
passenger in your own life and go like
everything is happening exactly as it
should and then you can cry then you can
have your feelings then you can just
like surrender yeah and what what if you
just didn't have to always be in the
fight or flight mode what if you didn't
have to always have cortisol firing your
adrenal fatigue like what if you were
just allowed to be like oh I wasn't born
to just work and stress and worry about
build like I was born to actually be
free and live and stop and smell the
roses like what if he just put it all
here so we could enjoy it a little more
all the other stuff's manmade would you
say that in terms of the feedback that
sort of triggers people would you say
when you're reading your Bible sermons
and stuff on Instagram would you say
that's the that's the thing uh what's
your question like would you say like do
PE does that like upset what would you
say triggers people the most oh um
because it feels like when I dance it oh
interesting they they're just like
they're they they they love to talk
about my Come on B you make it hurt so
good they love to talk about that video
and go I can't believe that girl who
vagina's falling out of her pants and
her boobs are falling out then turns
around and does this sermon I'm like I
didn't know that dance around was a
crime Jesus hung out with prostitutes so
Jesus was a goofball and furthermore he
was really
hot that that was the DAT of all
dudes
what that is my type of shit was a
goofball he was a goofball you know he
wasn't just walking around Parables he
probably like guys tired of listen to me
talk some fun you know he steered off
the beaten path every now and again was
like listen let's talk about what I
really want to talk about did you see
her you see her butt you who know but he
was just a
do he wasn't a perfect person this is
what kills me about you is like you'll
be reading a sermon or you'll be like
doing something and you'll be really
serious and then you'll just say
something you'll be like single female
single white female cuz I love the w w w
w w and then when you're like I
pronounce every letter in a word I'll
say salmon I pronounce Sal I'll say
salmon if it's there I'm sounding it out
peone call me the
pone the iseland why is the S there but
it's there so I'm going to make deal
yeah no one ever watched me so I'm going
to make sure everything gets noticed I
don't want this better to feel left out
is so sad you can't just ignore it
exactly I'm not I'm going to take my
sneakers off in front of this in
front maybe it's de so I think it's like
what you do is you're so many things and
that disorganizes people's brains who
just I'm disorganized you know but it's
like our brains want you to be one thing
they want you to be crazy and then when
you start making sense it's like no I
put you in the crazy box and now you're
making all the sense and then now you're
making sense and now you're making sense
about something I don't with because
religion now you're religious now you're
that like you're just so many things
they're like yeah what it's funny you
say that someone was like girl you're
all over the place like you got your RV
you got your religion I always had all
this like I'm a layered lady like an
onion like you know we all are we all
are very I'm on the edge of my seat
every time you post yeah you know maybe
I could refine it a bit I'm not going to
lie notes I I welcome notes um I have no
notes my only note is stop taking them
down sometimes you'll take them down I
know dude because I get I get so I get
so many bad notes I'm like oh okay let
me the race theace what makes you take
something down is it a message from a
friend shame or regret like I did
something
wrong yeah because I still have that
like bad bad girl you're a bad girl and
I'm like all right because I've never
just trusted in myself 100% not just
been like no it's all right like last
night Lori Petty calling me and I don't
care if she hears this we had talked for
a damn hour and then she goes so why
could we do signings together signing
conventions and she's like why aren't
you on the last like why aren't you on
the last bill I'm like I don't know we
have the same agent I'm like I don't
know but I don't care like I'm not going
to get in my head why why aren't they
having me to a signing convention
they're not fun to be honest and we go
all this time and she's being sweet just
like the time the Trump time and then
she goes so you need to take that shit
down like just went in for the kill I go
what shit I mean we're talking came out
of left field and I go what shit she's
like that stuff you're doing on uh on on
your IG you're never going to work again
I'm like do you think I give a fuck
and then our phone disconnected thank
God and she kept calling back I didn't
want to answer no like what was that
about you just you just wasted time my
time time I can never get back you're
just wasting my time time I can never
get back and so that's a big thing for
me now is how much you're stealing my
life is what I say you're steal you're
not I can't let you steal my life today
so sorry so that was that was pretty
lame but don't you think she's
projecting like you have a freedom that
I wish I had I like it I know I don't
know what it's all about I don't know
why people get so bummed on me like yet
but you just got two offers so you are
going to work again if you want to yeah
there's no there's no there's tons more
offers than ever and I have no agent no
manager nothing no no way yeah Hollywood
reporters are going to do a two-page
spread on me all about because I'm
different from other actresses it's
going to be I do it October 29th even a
photo shoot they're even paying makeup
artists like they're everyone's chuffed
by me they think it's hilarious I don't
know what's happening but I like it and
I'm not you know and I'm just like
whatever finally you guys when I don't
care anymore you're finally noticing but
I don't care I don't care I wish I was
married at had a husband and kids and
there's also I wish I was pregnant by
the way congratulations do the Johnson
and Johnson oh you I mean I don't know
what's in here it might be bab powder it
might be actual baby powder I'm going to
have a powdered baby this might I don't
know what's in here get it let's not
count our chicken that's over my head I
don't get it I don't get that joke I
don't get that one what does it mean cuz
Johnson and Johnson makes baby powder oh
and I got the Johnson Johnson oh okay
okay okay I just put it together it
yikes so a lot of people got vaccines
yeah hey guess it helps you not get
Co I like it when she's she's on her
videos and she's like the pandemic sorry
plandemic anyway you like can't help I
got Co Two Times by the way it was awful
and my eyesight went these are pres I
can't see anymore without like some type
of glasses on completely almost blind
was this the second one or the first one
Delta I had for four month omn the
second one I don't know just got got me
for months wow like I couldn't taste I
could and that's all neurological I mean
it was you want to hear was something
funny yes I was so desperate for money I
got offered to do big brother Celebrity
Big
Brother so I had to get the um
vaccination and everything and um and we
had to go into quarantine all together
in this hotel but I didn't know who the
opponents were or anything cuz they
don't tell you so we were ushered into a
hotel I got coid while being in
quarantine no in the hotel because
clearly someone didn't want me going on
that show so I always think it's hilar
is that I'm in quarantine in this hotel
they served our food like under the
under the door basically like we weren't
allowed they had put treadmills in our
room like we were stuck in a room like
we couldn't leave and I I get Co while
I'm in there what yeah so I didn't go on
Big Brother celebrity has there ever
been something that came along that you
were like I really need this money but I
just can't I can't do
it yeah yeah I got offers Dancing with
the Stars a couple years ago and it
ruined my I was like am I at this point
already like it was so you did it no I
didn't do it that'd be fun though to me
it hurt my feelings oh really oh no I
definitely was like oh I'm a real hasb
been when I got the celebrity brother
was like I was like so rude it was like
me and David Hasselhoff's daughter like
what I was just like
it's but you'd be amazing on daning with
the Stars you would probably win because
you're a dancer but you're it's funny
because I was like oh this is the end of
this is I've come to the end of the road
this is it big brother celebrity but I
think if you're actually really
interesting compelling authentic like
you it's not the end of the road it gets
people to see like oh this is a side of
who I've never seen before i' only seen
her play a drug addict a suicidal maniac
this white trash she's actually like
super aidite and smart and interesting
and nuanced and I want to see more of
her which is like I think what's kind of
happening right um well um I don't know
I just that it's just that I I don't
know how much I really care about the
business anymore I I think that there's
so much more to life so I just don't
know how much I care the more I don't
care the more it comes it's
wild interesting it's like it's like
it's like with any relationship but the
more you're chasing something you're
chasing it away yeah you know and the
more you're chasing something the less
you're aligned with God anyway and
you're just like all right attraction
not promotion like I always say like
this like if you if you had your your
palm of your hand out you had a pile of
sand sand you know that one and if you
if you open your fingers it slips
through if you hold it like this you can
hold it forever squeeze it too tight so
if you keep yeah but if you just hold it
just right then it just kicks it and
that's like that's life like just stop
pushing stop wanting it so bad yeah
because it's you're just basically like
pushing it away that's my thing I hold
on you don't care enough it then it
Slips Away M so it's just like find that
right balance you know and people feel
neediness they feel desperation they
feel when you want something and there's
something repellent about that totally
you know which is annoying because it's
like I hear these actresses they're like
and then I wrote a letter to the
director and then I showed up at his
house and I brought him cupcakes and I
got the job and I'm like I already come
off with such needy desperate manic
energy like I they would call the police
you know like I I can't do that shit
like I hear actresses talk about that
and they're like your boom box out I
know I'm just like I want is one line in
Two and a Half Men and they're like ah
she's mixtape yeah they put me in that
black card of Pennsylvania like I just
can't exactly you know it's like where I
come from whatever but it's just like I
that kind of need no want desperation
it's like when you know a girl gets
broken up when she keeps calling it
makes him not want you more it's when
you just dip and you vanish that they're
like hey I feel like something like this
there's something kind of so um healing
about how clarifying it is because are
people people in their life really
revealing themselves like sort of yeah
you know for me when something like this
you know happens I had sort of a I've
talked about a lot in the podcast a
manic episode in January you have manic
depression no I had a manic episode
after my mom died that's okay was I went
off birth control okay I went off proac
I went off drugs and everyone thought I
was on drugs but I was smoking weed and
I did the I micro doed those mushroom
like people were like oh this is great
for grief cuz I I couldn't cry but it
turns out it was being on birth control
you know that messes with your hormones
so much and I was watching my mom slowly
die in front of me and I wasn't crying
and I'm like I no pleas she was in a bed
for 12 years it was you know both my
parents had Strokes da and so um uh she
was in a bed it was sort of a nightmare
but I you took care of her yeah that's
yeah so it was you know I've I've gone
broke on American Healthcare System yeah
they both my parents had Strokes without
health insurance really yeah putting
them in nursing homes like ICU it's just
been like a nightmare wow who would have
thought you've been through all that
it's it's kind of a lot it's it's a lot
it's sort of this unique torture having
to just watch your parents die like
groundhog day but your parent your mom's
dying your dad's dying you know and just
have watching and you're paying all the
bills yeah yeah and they're miserable
and when you get a front row seat to the
ICU is $60,000 a day without what health
insurance you know it's what it's
markers um and so but I look at it you
know kind of as I go well it made me
work harder
iite whereas people like should I write
a TV show and I'm like I just had to
everyone's like how do you work so hard
I'm like I have fucking bills from like
Savannah you know fucking um Kaiser
Permanente in collections dude I don't
know you're just like should I become a
blogger or should I become a comedian
I'm like with your trust funds trying to
figure out what you're going to do like
I there's urgency totally like I had to
did you get to um do some jokes for your
dad I did a little bit a little bit it
was I was actually talking about this
the other day like my dad was really
hard on me in a way because I come from
Sports you know probably the same you
come with ballet like Perfection is key
he wanted boys um he you know his dad
was in a war um you know we come from
coal mining and apple there wasn't a lot
of emotion his way of loving me which it
took me a long time to figure it out was
always not congratulating me on what I
did well but going like you could have
done that better oh and at the time it
really hurt and I think in my 20s I was
kind of like that was man that was and
now I look back and I'm like I look at
my friends that got unconditional love
from their parents and they're fucking
wrecks wow really yeah I'm like you know
so for me it's like it's it's he that's
the way he was showing me love and
making it so that I had this like work
ethic and I was able to you know you see
Comics that are like oh the audience
sucked he would never he'd be like you
could have done it this way like he so I
didn't get the ulation that I thought I
wanted but I got the great love that I
think I've needed yeah the prob so when
they say they're proud it's like like
means something yeah my mom never so my
dad was different he was proud my mom my
mom was hard is hard on me so I get I
know what that feels like if I'm a you
know I'm having a boy but if I had a
daughter I got to say I feel like I'd be
really hard on her because if I'm not
hard on you the world's going to be hard
on you and I feel like my my dad was
always like I gotta be hard on you in
here because if I'm not then you're
going to have to deal with it out there
and I'd rather be me you think he was
that like he had it all planned out like
that much or he was just being him I
think he I think he because he would
always tell me life's not fair like he
would tell me really brutal shit he was
never like you're G to make it and you
can do anything he's like you can be the
most talented person but if you don't
work the hardest you're never going to
win yeah he's like and then he would um
uh wake me up in the middle of the night
and test me for um note cards and for
tests coming up wow and for pop quizzes
in the middle of the night which it's
this seems like crazy abuse I know and
he'd be like the um spelling words he be
like I have to do all the spelling words
and i' like why are we doing this at two
in the morning like other kids don't do
this it's like because you don't know
you might be tired during the test you
might have to pee during the test like
something's going to distract you and
throw you you're never going to be
tested in a situation where you're
physically comfortable what do you think
the point was of all this I'm funny with
that question a lot of people in my life
what's your fiveyear plan and I I don't
have those I literally always maybe it's
my Buddhism days I'm just super present
just day by day I worry about bills
sometimes I'm like oh boy because I
don't like collections I don't like bad
credit you know I'm definitely like but
I don't really have a plan I
just but do you think in terms of like
God's plan for you you've had to hold in
and keep other people's secrets for so
long and something we say in program is
you're only as sick as the secrets you
keep and I just it's been so um I'm just
like I get so happy when I watch you exp
punching secrets you know like when you
talked about the pasta sauce sorry oh
the pasta sauce oh I could use that
money right now too that was supposed to
be my friend too like that I was helping
she just doesn't give a
shit at all like she just she just
basically thought that I just gave that
to her even though we signed a contract
so yeah but then there's feel like you
don't have to air all your dirty laundry
out on IG I'm like oh this is nothing
yeah yeah like seriously dry cleaning
yeah this is me already like already
like filtering it gnarly you know like
there's a lot more I would love to talk
about all the stuff that is going on you
know yeah just it's been a really it's
been a great business I've had a blast
but it's also been really sad you know
like even going back to like Britney
Murphy like that was my pal and like
what happened to her and Britney Spears
like like I I worked with her day day by
day I mean she she was awesome
sweetheart and so kind and um you know
just I think she's I mean I don't know
what's going on with her but it's like
just sad to see the the dismantling of
people's Souls you it also is to get
5150 with what happened to her whatever
collusion and she had 5150 going up
what's up she had a 51 she had well her
dad was able to basically become her
conservator right and in the state of
California you someone can't do that to
you if you can say the date and your
name so if she was able to say the date
and her name to the judge none of this
could have happened and I have a very
hard time believing she couldn't do that
MH I mean she's pretty she's pretty with
it you know so unless it was just they
try to get her to do it under poor
conditions like if she
was half asleep you know what I mean
like then it's you know and when you
watch her you're like she was so um
Brave and Brazen and on top of her shit
and would choreograph her own stuff like
she wasn't like a plant an industry
plant she wasn't like a puppet that was
ort of this like um constructed pop star
you know and then you see what happened
to her personality I actually did a
thing on um the podcast that was because
ndas really scare people and her dad
really scared people the non-disclosure
agreements and anyone so I was like
there's no way her dad can be doing all
of this her dad can't be jamming the
pills down her throat and making sure
she doesn't leave and hiding the keys
how am I going to drive my car that's
her
Anthem and um and I was like so there's
got to be at least 20 people that are
enforcing saying him keeping her in
prison right I find it interesting um
cuz when I was on the movie there was a
woman named fee do do you know who fee
is so fee was like her her like side
side I mean basically like an assistant
of sorts older woman
beautiful kind woman and fee was always
around she's a real deep southern accent
and she was wonderful and suddenly she's
nowhere I think it's weird that Lynn
Spears is nowhere to be found like how
come they never speak on it
um I went to a club like maybe a few
years ago like let's say maybe eight
years ago and this bodyguard that was
working pulled me aside like pulled
yanked me away from my friends and told
me a bunch of stuff like he needed to
get it off his chest and I was like oh D
I had that happen with a a cleaning lady
in Portland because I did this whole
thing where I said if you work for uh
Britney and you're someone that's
helping cut up the pills or whatever
doser or you know um I will pay your NDA
violation fee H so and all these people
started emailing me coming up to me
there was a security guard or sorry a
cleaning lady in Portland who came up to
me in a hotel and she said I cleaned
Britney's Room at Planet Hollywood and
they took my phone before I went in and
there were two security guards next to
her at all times while I was just
cleaning her room so yeah it just makes
me feel that so so you're right so
basically like um like the day we went
got our tattoo so I have a tattoo and
she saw it and she wanted it so big Rob
took us that day to the tattoo parlor
and she copied my tattoo off me it's
smaller but like yeah there's always
somebody and um we all went out one
night and um you know but the bodyguards
are everywhere you know but she's she's
still allowed to do some stuff but you
never could have her without somebody
around that's true what did The
Bodyguard say at the nightclub a couple
years
ago I don't know I don't know if I
should go there does it Dart in your
neck I just yeah I just like yeah I just
I I don't want to disrespect her privacy
and but it wasn't about her to be honest
it was about somebody else and but he
was upset he was tearing up and I
couldn't remember him but he could
remember me and he was just so upset
we're talking so upset V visually so
shook and it's also it's like the kind
of thing that not a lot of people have
compassion for but nobody really talks
about the trauma of Fame I think that
they brok in her sister's mind
too you know it's like you know like her
sister turning on her like someone put
her up to that she doesn't want to do
that to her money does wild things to
people's brains too MH you know
especially if you didn't have it growing
up and then all of a sudden you have it
it just scrambles your brain yeah and
also that dad seems like real trash yeah
person I never met him I met I met Lynn
but not her dad and then with Britney
Murphy like looking at these cases is
there a little part of you that's like
oh thank God I interesting that Britney
Murphy bought Britney Spears's house
that was covered in black mold and
that's why Britney Spears moved out and
then Britney Murphy bought that house
I just I always thought that was
interesting like black mold is very
dangerous for health so I always thought
that was interesting because she died
with like pneumonia I think like
pneumonia and just like out of nowhere I
mean the documentary about that guy
Simon who I think had the same drugs in
his system or something and him the mom
him and the mom were in cahoots I mean I
think it's like there was a lot of
really spooky shit around that do you
ever sort of feel like you're glad you
didn't get to that that level
when you say like I don't get out to
star in movies you know what I mean when
you say that like do you think there's a
level of Fame that is just too dangerous
for yeah so yeah yeah if you don't drink
the Kool-Aid you don't drink the gold
juice so I was offered the gold juice
three times in my 20s my 30s and
pee lot of golden showers and the gold
juice that I will live forever and I'll
have whatever I want the gold
juice you never offered the gold juice
no I'm I'm a scumbag comic what's the
gold juice I don't know I don't know but
I didn't drink it and I didn't want it
and I noticed when all the girls certain
girls on Orange um changed yeah it's a
real thing it's like a real thing like
it's all a real thing and it's scary
because they send like people after you
and they can like kind of moonlight as
like a friend
or you know and and their wolf and
sheep's clothing and and and listen you
can have everything you want all the
fame in the world all the money I'm like
hm what if I just drank it but then I
you know what I mean like what if I and
I don't know what it is it's if it's a
metaphor for the gold juice like you
feel them what I'm what I'm what I'm
saying
mostly and um if there's a tincture that
makes you younger I better know where
you better let me in on this if adrenic
is real I'll be you can put you know um
some of some of the women put like some
type of like like baby Force skin on
their face or sure sure why do you think
I'm having a kid
I want to be a mother wow insane Kevin
spy already called dibs on this he just
he just wired Me 2 Millie to my PayPal
that's
[Laughter]
all oh man so there I mean I I did I
don't believe in all that adren Chrome
so I'm like there's just no way that all
that no cuz if it existed I'd be there
right now I'd be at the piz
place but it's also it's interesting
though because when people have these
like conspiracy theories online about
like people in Hollywood what hiss yeah
that we all just electrocute babies it's
like we just you have a baby bre it also
by the way I mean so annoying most women
in like are infertile because of all the
trash we put in our bodies the last
thing we're going do is eat a baby if we
have one it's hard enough to get one but
also just have to eat it when I when I
think we don't carbs we're not getting
human baby um we're all intermittent
fast babies aren't keto I'm ban um but
exactly but to me I'm always like no no
the truth is so much worse than these
wild rumors that you guys are coming up
with I mean child acting to me is always
wild any child acting in general like
why is child labor illegal yet child
acting is okay like I don't to me and I
got you know I did take a video down on
Instagram recently and I'm so pissed
because I was talking about sound of
freedom and obviously movie so important
the guy that made it you know had some
allegations from the he was telling
women like if you just shower together
in front of me you'll save some children
which is wait which one Tim the guy T
Ballard yeah yeah which is if it if it
saves kids rub a dub dub bitch like sure
I don't know maybe that was part of it I
don't know rub ducky
the like who cares like he made you
shower with someone these kids are
getting trafficked shut up like just say
no and move on just pull in anything
they can yeah any guy will do that every
guy will try to yeah exactly like just I
I he's good he takes big swings maybe
he's GNA get more kids out I don't know
it's like you're getting kids out sure
I'll take a shower for you like whatever
you just you earned it Bud yeah um but I
was once you've been in Hollywood
someone asked you to take a shower with
another woman I know
sure that's all me in coach
yeah just the idea that you're like we
went to go rescue children from Thailand
that were getting trafficked and he
asked me to take a shower it's like you
think you're the traumatized person
and just like move on and so I so I had
said like yes but also I do find it
weird that there are child actors in The
Sound a freedom movie because being a
child actor is also good kind of spooky
and are these kids really consenting to
play victims of this horrific thing are
they going to grow up teach them and
what are you what are the director
saying like you need to look scared
because this m i i just wow that's deep
I don't know but to me I'm like you guys
are like let's stop trafficking kids
meanwhile you know you're traumatizing
these actors are people are dragging
these 5-year-olds out to buring to go
stand in front of adults and like cry on
C and pretend you know what I mean it
was my thing is just like use CGI kids
or midgets and it's called small people
it's called they're called
pipsqueaks the official PC term I've
worked with a lot of them they're called
Little Darlings that's what we call them
now that's cute strong babies strong
babies tall babies so with funny voices
so I don't have the solution I'm just
saying if you're against child
trafficking you also probably are like
yet okay you're so you're against child
trafficking you'd love to see a
six-year-old give a dramatic monologue
like what like why is this kid a really
good point why aren't they in school why
aren't they I mean I also I'm obsessed
with Shirley Temple I mean when people
are like is Hollywood creepy I'm like it
was built on the back of a four-year-old
child named Shirley Temple who used to
twerk on men on boats that's your thing
um
a
rock and she's remember Charley tble
movies she's always like at war with a
bunch of men there's no Mom tap dancing
around like a buffalo she with a little
with their when you know enough about
there a drink a shely temple it's a yeah
I mean when uh you know enough about the
business the way we do you know like
every shot was choreographed for weeks
right her wardrobe they perfectly hemmed
it to show her little bloomers and her
diapers and the and she's there's um The
Good Ship Lollipop dude that it's kind
of a Bop but it's her and a bunch of men
like on a train and she's just dancing
for them there's no nanny there's no
woman she's just yeah and they're loving
it like go was like let's go see Shirley
Temple at the theater and watch this
four-year-old her F Mother where are the
where the and there's I mean dude
there's also one where she's in
blackface that would give Justin Trudeau
a run for his money um they're like when
you're putting shoe polish on a
four-year-old like take a good hard look
you haven't seen Charlie templ in black
face
no as a young like when she was young
good is that just like a facial mask
like to like she was I I honestly I
don't know CU I I really don't want to
dig more into that um I never saw that
it's traumatizing but like she's just
yeah it's like why are kids in movies
and Brook Shields in in Lagoon when she
had her first Blood you're like what
yeah that was W also my favorite movies
Labyrinth and but he was he's different
yeah I mean Jennifer Connelly was like
15 David Boe was like I don't know he's
a vampire though he's
ageless David Bo it doesn't count yeah
the my favorite you know but it's like
you I just and also it's like with these
shows about teenagers like we know how
these work why is some 50-year-old man
writing dialogue for a teenage girl what
do you think it is what's happening I
just think it's
like I just think we're in a spooky
business and I think men have run it for
the longest time and you know I think I
think animated movies like kids you can
do kids movies without using kids you
know and I think that using children in
television is just it's worked it's been
popular Hannah Montana all this and then
we see the ramifications we see what
happens to these children and we're like
oh Amanda bind Britney Spears da d da
child acting destroys these people but
we're kind of okay with it and then we
want to beat up on them and make fun of
them yeah that that that parts off yeah
she's a mess she's DUI like I mean
Amanda binds I don't know exactly what's
going on but watching the internet just
have this field day with girl we watched
grow up and have to be an adult it's I
mean you know being on a TV set like you
have to be an adult when you're a child
yeah I started at 19 officially so I was
a little yeah I was you're a little bit
older yeah but I know like Kirsten dun
start like uh the Vampire movie like
thir like she was young with yes The
Interview with the Vampire so yeah like
watching her because she was in my class
and yeah they coddled her a lot because
because of that but she's turned out
like all right yeah no she's she's yeah
she's a she has a good mom um but yeah
you're right dad though when he really
that's I'm just sit here like damn when
I see child actors in dramas that are
about sex trafficking I'm just kind of
like that child didn't I mean do do they
know what the subject matter is if not
they're going to find out pretty soon
and then we know the logistics of
auditioning like how did how is this
child picked where they like yeah she
looked like she looks like a tra yeah or
she looks like someone someone would
want to traffic she look she looks like
she'd go for like what is that
conversation none of it good like I
don't like any of it you know that's
just not a situation I think a child
should be in but then you're like well
this movie should get made if it's but
is it making it I don't know should it
have been a documentary I don't know the
answer it was like it was like one of
one of Tim's like I guess probably his
greatest account of saving kids but it's
like there's such a deeper issue that
feels like it's about Tim that's how I
felt about it a little bit it just when
you know what's really going on and why
does he have a publicist like why is Tim
on the talk he's gotten grumpy too he
used to be like really really nice and
happy but he's kind of gotten like I
just don't even enjoy looking at him
anym talk yeah I think it's like to me
it's sort of like if you know how to get
kids out why are you doing anything else
but or also tell us how to do like if
you're going to go on The View and talk
about your new book like can you let us
we'll head over to Vietnam or wherever
like why are you final question you're
doing the crossroads uh a Q&A tonight
kind of thing is there a Q&A I don't
know is there a Q&A maybe we're just
going I guess it came out re it like re
um yeah they're showing it cuz she put
out a book and so they like I don't know
is it what what's the dates it's like
October was it Friday Saturday Sunday oh
tomorrow today and tomorrow are we
releasing it yeah so we're going just to
have fun and yeah just just because it's
fun it's it's Britney dude we love
Britney dude it's Britney it's
Crossroads but why someone took your
name off it or not it's back on I mean
we have the poster from Croatia oh yeah
they didn't put me in like Rolling
Stones I don't even know what the fuck
this poster is where' you find this I
don't even know I think we mocked it up
in the back there there but yeah so like
some of the main Publications didn't add
me they they put Zoe sell Dan and
Britney Spears in Dan
arroy I'm like is that Dan
arroy people don't like me I don't know
why I don't know what I did I love you
and I hate everyone yeah I don't know
why the right people love you yeah
that's all that matters the right people
get it that's all that matters um thank
you for doing this absolutely and
hopefully taran's gonna start a
podcast I love to I think you should
don't you think I mean I don't know if I
could like I don't know if I have that
same like leadership quality like you do
how you can lead it like that i' have to
learn you can know you do what you're
already doing in your videos but you
just don't have to jam it into three
minutes you know and you can kind of
just we'll see we'll talk about it yeah
but it's like you have like so much
wisdom and you have such a big heart and
um I think we need more of that a thank
you buddy I really like you you're
awesome I was so excited and my friends
were excited to meet you so thank you
for having me and thank you for trusting
me and seeing me not making fun of me I
just it's like looking in a mirror nice
I end these very awkwardly don't ride
elephant tan
Manning is
[Music]
yay
[Applause]
m